les séries laeticia hallyday at elle le
droit de retrouver l'amour puisque c'est
notre dossier du jour elle aurait déjà
retrouvé l'amour on l'a vu dans les
journaux people ce week end et c'est
vrai que ça divise beaucoup beaucoup de
monde près de deux ans après la mort de
johnny l'idéal a retrouvé l'amour parce
qu'elle serait tombée amoureuse cet été
d'un certain pascal ballon on vous
explique tout ça sur cette nouvelle
histoire qui divise déjà les fans
regardent et voici une nouvelle
information au sujet de laëtitia qui
fait parler depuis quelques jours cette
fois ci c'est la vie privée de la veuve
du chanteur qui intrigue
d'après le magazine voici laëtitia
aurait retrouvé l'amour
c'est cet été à saint bar qu'elle aurait
fait grâce à des amis en commun la
rencontre de pascal un restaurateur
parisien de 47 ans tout de suite c'est
le coup de coeur il passe le reste des
vacances ensemble
rentré à los angeles et lui à paris elle
lui demande de venir la rejoindre à et
les pour passer du temps à ses côtés ce
qu'il accepte immédiatement sylvia paris
il connaît bien le son de jeu l'aise
puisque sa fille est scolarisée la bad
dans le même lycée que jade et joy les
filles de johnny et laeticia une sacrée
coïncidence
depuis quelques temps les deux
tourtereaux ne se quittent plus et font
même des activités en présence de leurs
enfants
si cet amour semble sans bague il ya
pourtant certaines personnes à qui cette
union fait grincer des dents pour eux
deux ans seulement après la disparition
du taulier il est trop tôt pour tourner
la page quand pour d'autres il est tout
à fait normal que laëtitia puisse
refaire sa vie alors pour vous laetitia
at elle le droit de retrouver l'amour
elle serait tombée donc sous le charme
de pascal ballon qui était en vacances à
saint barth en même temps que laetitia
bernard montiel oui alors s'est passé
cet été au mois d'août
pascal ballan était présentée par
clément bizeray vous savez quel ex
d'alexandra sublet away toi qui connais
tous les bye bye oui là je vous
expliquais en plus donc ça s'est passé
sur le bateau véritable coup de foudre
elle assume totalement cet amour là ils
sont tombés fous d'amour alors parce
qu'à balancer qui c'est le fils de
l'éditeur ballon qui est décédé et il
est un demi frère qui était l'ancien
directeur d'antenne de tf1 qui est
maintenant consultant tf1 ses cinq
balles en voilà et les divorcée deux
fois
hélas deux filles déjà et une première
fille avec sa première femme qui
s'appelle marine qui vit à los angeles
est pour ça qu après saint barth
il est parti à los angeles retrouvez sa
première femme donc avec laquelle il
s'entend très bien
ils ont une gosse de 14 ans qui est qui
et donc sa fille il est allé célébrer
l'anniversaire qui sont revus là-bas
évidemment hilare épouser une autre
personne avec laquelle il a une autre
fille c'est un mec très bien qu'à deux
restaurants à paris il est très
sympathique
de l'avis de tous soyez j'ai demandé
j'ai appelé ce matin les copains il
allait très bien il le trouve très bien
c'est un mec très belle enquête alors
est ce que ça vous choque que laëtitia
s'affiche déjà avec un nouveau compagnon
alors on a donc christine kelly qui est
avec nous parce que vous avez eu la
réaction de laëtitia juste après cette
une
voilà des journaux people parce qu'elle
elle s'en cache pas du tout hein vous ne
l'avez dit montiel pas du tout c'est la
première fois qu'elle qu'elle montre
vrai mari ah oui là c'est la première
fois qu'elle assume totalement elle est
folle amoureuse elle va y aller elle est
arrivée aujourd'hui à paris d'ailleurs
et saad est arrivé à paris à libérer qui
a été très souriante
voilà oui évidemment maintenant elle est
amoureuse c'est bien moi the town
formidable alors il est propriétaire de
plusieurs restaurants branchés dans le
quartier les quartiers chics de paris
2 c'est ça de ma merci bon moi j'en ai
trois apparemment tu d'enlever un
restaurant et qui signifie qu'elle a été
la réaction de dollars dans la droite
ligne de ce qu'a dit bernard sa réaction
vendredi lorsque l'article est sortie
elle a réuni sa famille ses enfants son
compagnon la fille justement qu est-ce
qu scolarisés à los angeles et elle
s'est dite soulagée que ce soit apparue
drowsy est ce qu'elle a fait exprès ou
pas dit la vérité est ce que c'est on se
dit pourquoi les s10 salata ne soulage
pas vraiment b
in fine le rôle elle a envie de
l'affiché maintenant je sais que ça
partage ça divise énormément sur les
réseaux mais moi je trouve que vous
voyez et dieu sait que je la rate pas un
mais là je vous dis je suis très heureux
pour elle j'espère comme ça tout va
s'adoucir que les rapports seront
meilleurs qu'ils avaient à réussir à
transformer un peu les conflits qui a eu
avec son premier avocat qu'elle a viré
et qu'elle a réussi maintenant à
s'adoucir avec cette histoire une femme
amoureuse et une femme plus aimable
alors et en russe ella ella on va parler
dans un instant d'optique de petites
choses si vous avez d'autres infos juste
on avec nous maria membres de
l'association johnny blouson rouge et
noir voilà merci en tout cas d'être avec
nous maria maria vous vous êtes fan de
johnny et chez les fans on est très très
partagés vous dites vous c'est trop tôt
pour qu'elle refasse sa vie ça fait
quand même besoin qu'elle refasse sa vie
c'est tout à fait normal
elle est jeune oui non à laquelle hd
titia d'ailleurs à la 44 ans accord ni
l'huile à 48 d'accord et l'a40 dacquois
là mais je trouve que c'est de l'affiché
comme ça au bout d'un an et demi je
trouve que c'est un petit peu trop tôt
pour quoi ça vous a choqué vous ça m'a
choqué parce que moi je suis veuf depuis
quatre ans j'arrive pas faire mon deuil
donc j'aimerais bien qu'un mix et
peut-être qu'elle n'arrive pas à faire
son deuil mais qu'elle est là quand même
elle aime toujours johnny enfin des six
mois est la bonne elle avait besoin
quand même de deux roues sûrement mais
ça passe pas auprès des fans
nous on est les organisateurs des messes
à la madeleine tous les mois tous les 9
du mois
on a sans arrêt mille personnes qui
viennent à la messe et on en entend des
vertes et des pas mûres à côté de nous
raconter ce que vous les entendez 195 1
johnny et laeticia se rencontrent pour
la première fois cette rencontre n'a
rien d'un hasard puisque c'est andré
boudou comme on l'a dit le père de
laeticia qui a tout organisé où les
gourmands traitement parce
qu'aujourd'hui
voilà laetitia a envie de refaire sa vie
regarde la rencontre va avoir lieu dans
la discothèque la plus branchée de miami
l'amnesia
le patron s'appelle andré boudou ce 25
mars il va insister lourdement auprès de
sa fille laetitia 20 ans pour qu'elles
accompagnent passé la soirée avec johnny
hallyday et qui s'est pas super
enthousiaste genis un puzzle de son père
a forcément son idole à elle et c'est à
contrecoeur que la jeune femme se rend à
l'amnesia tête ici à tombe mais vraiment
tout de suite qu'amoureuse de johnny de
son regard d'aigle de son regard bleu
acier et à 6 heures du matin sur le
parking du boîtier ils échangeront leur
premier baiser
alors voilà donc là c'était avec johnny
aujourd'hui on voit c'est la première
fois depuis johnny qu'on la voit
s'afficher avec un autre compagnon donc
c'est vrai que c'était incroyable moi
c'est une je pense ça c'est quand même
un gros coup là il ce journal people oui
ça jamais moi je comprends que ça choque
des personnes il ya on dit souvent on
continue on refait pas sa vie on la
continue c'est normal qu'elle refasse sa
vie le problème c'est que comme elle
s'est drapé depuis des mois et des mois
dans le costume de la veuve de la veuve
éplorée et là c'est là mais l'un
n'empêche pas l'autre minutes laissait
le fait d'expliquer ce que peuvent
ressentir les gens savaient qu'on a
beaucoup vu laeticia communiquer sur le
drame qu'elle a vécu et on comprend sur
la difficulté de refus de vivre avec
avec ce deuil et de passer de ce cette
situation-là à ça en un clin d'oeil ça
choque les gens et c'est normal c'est
normal denis est bien évidemment un
monument français est dans la tête des
gens elle a effacé deux disques et je
skie pas le cas bien sûr mais dans la
tête des gens je comprends que ça choque
évidemment réagissiez dessus puisque
tout le monde a un avis là dessus
moi j'ai vu même les plus jeunes qui
sont fous totalement il avait un avis
disait vous avez vu laëtitia le
nouveau-mexique anne bernard
c'est la première histoire sérieuse
qu'elle a depuis johnny ben c'est la
première histoire assumer maintenant lui
a prêté tellement d'autres aventures on
n'est sûr de rien c'est quoi là c'est
vraiment ça c'est sûr elle aime elle le
dit elle déclare je croyais moi ça va y
allait lui aussi
l affaire des couvertures avec le sens
du mal à y aller va l'acheter dès
l'ouverture
de quoi penser que ça peut aller au
mariage
abela non je dis pas jusqu'au mariage
ils viennent de se rencontrer au mois
d'août ça va aller très vite en nous
savons déjà sa fille à lui à los angeles
était à l'école avec la petite
on va essayer déjà six voiliers un truc
ce trailer est ce qu'on va aller au
mariage ou poste et je voulais vous
montrer les mariages les images du
mariage de johnny et laeticia c'est à
neuilly sur seine
c'était très très très médiatisé et
c'est vrai que mine de rien quand on
voit ça on a du mal à imaginer laetitia
avec avec quelqu'un d'autre regarde ce
jour là toute l'attention est sûre la
star johnny hallyday sa cinquième épouse
laeticia passe presque inaperçue un mois
avant le mariage johnny décide de lui
faire une surprise
il lui dit dans un mois on se marie
c'est même pas tu veux ou tu veux passer
non dans un mois ans marie
laetitia marie-christine vous consommez
pas prendre vous pouvez nous monsieur
jean philippe smet ici présentes
c'est un peu sourd mais c'est suffisant
alors voilà donc c'est vrai que depuis
ça depuis johnny on l'avait jamais vu
quelqu'un avec moi quand j'ai vu ça
c'est vrai vendredi et plein de georges
méliès qu'elle a le droit de retrouver
l'amour est ce que ça va être bien vu
jean michel fugain une grande part de
machisme dans ce genre d'engin hilal par
des réactions des fans qui sont outrés
parce que quand un homme ce qu'un homme
devient veuf ton s'allient pour essayer
de présenter quelqu'un pour qui
rebondisent qui reprenne sa joie de
vivre et quand c'est une femme elle est
la lacune quand droite restant au noir
toute sa vie et pleurer son mari en en
une fabrici m'attend là monsieur vous
êtes accepte on a simplement dit que
c'était trop tôt n'a pas trop été
vraiment elle était vraiment c'était le
couple idéal en tomber amoureux
c'était trop tôt pour que s'affiche et
ses savants sa fichier nommé qu'elle
repasserait maintenant mais qu'elle
refasse sa vie c'est tout à fait normal
elle est jeune c'est tout à fait normal
et je pense même que johnny aurait
approuvé oui ça fait ça fait deux ans
qu'il aurait approuvé mais là je trouve
qu'elle s'est affichée un peu d'eux
voulait qu'à attendre combien de temps
marié encore ah bah non ben je sais pas
mais bon elle s'est quand même affiché à
saint barth
on l'a vu sur les bateaux s'éclater
enfin bon moi je dois vivre mais pas
qu'elle s'exhibe comme ça juste photo
reuters sur toute la journée
oui mais pas les appels via réoccupation
par mois ici six ils voulaient juste
envie si on paie mariage je pense pas
que johnny aurait voulu que laeticia se
cloîtrent chez zen et café je vous ai
dit john il aurait sûrement prouver
c'est hollande n'est pas agrégée non
alors est ce qu a le droit de faire ça
dit la caisse et bien sûr elle a le
droit de refaire sa vie elle a le droit
de vivre un très grand amour ou ya aucun
souci là-dessus le problème c'est
qu'elle nous habituer à occuper
systématiquement le déficit éthiques
dans tous les cas de figure les
histoires du baptême ya quinze jours qui
était grotesque personne n'était allé la
chercher
c'est elle qui a imposé sa les photos de
couverture est les demanderesses donc là
brusquement
c'est très bien on est ravi pour elle
mais on peut pas dire que brusquement
voilà c'est on en découvre elle a
toujours occupé le terrain médiatique et
d'une façon elle continue à le faire
ils sont que là c'est un véritable grand
amour mais elle va occuper y aura les
interviews y aura chez fogiel y aura on
peut déjà vous dire le plan de com
christine vous avez vous eu des infos
juillet alors d'écrire cette réaction
alors c'est pas sa déclaration que sinon
mais le fait qu'elle s'est dit soulagé
d'en céder tout larsson de koné la
réaction de laëtitia cslc ça c'est
lorsqu'elle quand elle a vu la cour et
ses dires on est tranquille village et
un design qui d'ailleurs est là elle se
sont échangé un coup de fil avec mamy
rock donc la maman d'andré boudou
rappelle quand même que son cercle est
très rare et récits après avoir évincé
tout le monde donc auprès de la famille
boudou et mamy rock aurait semble-t-il
approuvé cette nouvelle relation et ça
aussi c'est nouveau d'accord donc ça dit
long sur cette relation
voilà donc cei tout le monde approuve
tout le monde a envie que ça mon
approuve les enfants sur l'ensemble la
famille ensemble la famille boudou
approuvent et là on dirait que c'est une
nouvelle ère complètement pour aurel qui
a balayé est ce que c'est un série dure
pour vous quand vous avez vu la une de
ce journal people mariale pour les fans
de johnny un coup dur pour moi non parce
que comme je vous disais elle a le droit
à la le droit de refaire sa vie elle est
jeune
un coup dur non mais les autres fans
pour cercle des fans m'avaient dit que
vous aviez entendu plein de choses il a
oui mais c'est des gros mots et j'ai pas
envie de lui en bien gérée grove est à
peu près qu'il dise et quoi non m'at il
disait que bon c'est la veuve éplorée
il ya quelques jours et elle pleurait
m'attends à s'exhibe enfin bon la veuve
noire enfin la veuve joyeuse c'est parce
que tu es un homme qu'elle aime dans mes
bras c'est dans le désamour ça vous
choque moi ça me choque week on traite
les femmes comme ça
désolé même christine qui dit elle a eu
l'approbation une femme n'a pas besoin
de l'approbation des autres pour aimer
quelqu'un s'est rapproché de son père et
par les patrons justement et elle a
parlé au père à la mère de son père je
me tourne vers marjah vous avez dit
qu'il ya plein de femmes qui parlaient
mal de laëtitia oui il ya eu quand même
quelques mois après leur mariage il ya
le magazine voici aussi qui a annoncé
que johnny avec une relation avec une
autre femme
johnny va tout faire pour cacher son
infidélité laëtitia mais la vérité va
éclater au grand jour
ça voulait dire qu'on voulait supprimer
le droit parce que vous acceptez de la
part de johnny et laeticia c'est vrai
que c'est plus compliqué après je vous
jette pas la pierre
regardez juste cette expérience pour le
chanteur l' affaire tombe au pire moment
dans quelques heures il doit rejoindre
laetitia me
pour partir en lune de miel sur son
bateau alors johnny hallyday a une idée
emmené laetitia au plus vite en
croisière avant qu'elle n'ait le voici
entre les mains cette lune de miel
démarre très mal d'autant qu'à la
première escale à porto rico
laetitia fini par découvrir le
pot-aux-roses c'est reculer pour mieux
sauter puisque quelques jours après ce
andré boudou qui montrera à sa fille la
couverture de voici et là bas c'est là
que petit illusion castany qui dit moi
aussi ça m'est arrivé je suis parti en
angleterre
si on n'allait pas le retrouver alors
vous acceptez que johnny que j'accepte
c'est que laëtitia savait comment été
johnny elle savait que johnny c'était
c'était un homme à fans et on dira titre
on dira que le documentaire de france 3
johnny alors oui agathe est parmi les
réactions autour de l'officialisation
donc de laëtitia de son nouvel amour il
y avait non seulement ceux qui pensaient
que c'était trop tôt parce que johnny il
était particulièrement ému et aussi ceux
qui disaient qu'elle l'a rencontré en
août
là on est à peine fin septembre et déjà
c'est l'officialisation ça fait à peine
un mois de relation et déjà c'est un
grand amour et tout donc y avait plein
de plein de circonstance pour rien
bristol c'est pas ça c'est pas ça la
question et après quand on se mit à deux
minutes à la place de laeticia hallyday
non seulement elle a dû faire face au
deuil d'une personne avec qui elle est
restée pendant plus de vingt ans qu'elle
a aimé plus que tout et en plus elle a
dû faire face au lynchage à la haine
dans cette histoire d'héritage et c'est
donc là qu'elle retrouve un peu d'air
frais un peu d'oxygène un nouvel amour
souhaitons lui le tout bonus tienne deux
enfants et bien sûr dont il fait une
réaction je deviens un peu d'air frais
un peu d'amour mais justement après tout
cette relation pendant tout son mariage
avec johnny on n'a jamais vu une comme
ça jamais jamais en revanche on a vu on
a vue d'aider des fuites on va dire du
côté de johnny hallyday donc je trouve
que c'est quand même respectueux que ce
soit après deux ans après on a pas on
peut pas juger plus loin vers la montée
en tout cas on repart vraiment j'ai
appelé vraiment des amis à eux donc pas
vraiment d'un coup de foudre
c'est très sincère et très fort et je
suis très content pour elle les dieu
sait que je n'ai pas ménagé ici parce
qu'effectivement au niveau de la com
elle a été nulle
alors elle est arrivée à paris elle va
rester convainc en dix jours elle part
le 25 et le 26 septembre
d'accord voilà très bien alors
envoi sommaire d'ailleurs et tout ça on
voit tout le monde là elle re prépare
l'offensive parce que le 6 novembre à
versailles il ya l'appel qu'elle a fait
à propos des six résidents français ou
pas donc là ils sont en train de revoir
un peu toute leur politique à la fois de
communication qui était à chier jusqu'à
présent c'est en train de se retourner
l'implant oui oui alors elle a fait elle
a tenté dé négocier mais c'est pas alors
il ya certains fans de johnny qui ce
week end ont été déçus par laetitia elle
s'est pas rendu à brignoles dans le var
où étaient inégaux riz inauguré une
nouvelle statue à l'effigié de johnny la
statue grandeur nature de données et de
signer du sculpteur christian mas elle
estime à 90 milles euros et villes comme
saint tropez sûr intéressé pour
récupérer cette statue laëtitia n'a fait
qu'une apparition publique depuis la
mort de johnny vous le savez c'était le
15 juin dernier lors de l'inauguration
de l'esplanade johnny hallyday a tous
voila l ai déjà vu jenny d'homme ça
n'est pas la statue de johnny allait là
bas non allez on savait même pas un
sosie un choix et nous allons donc où
comparaissent pour ça non mais c'est
peut-être pour ça qu'il y ait pas les 90
euros là a dit mme faucheur de johnny
pour aj sexy toi sur laëtitia tel le
droit de retrouver l'amour oui j'en ai
je des manifestations en l'honneur de
johnny date ce week-end dans toute la
france c'est normal des fans et sur la
fin de leur vie fans de johnny ne peut
pas aller dans tous tes mains c'est
station north john mc clain sa femme si
quand même vous forcément que laeticia
elle doit encore vous et toute sa vie à
johnny non non non pas toute sa vie mais
lasses à peine deux ans donc elle a bien
été à toulouse un bien sûr cette
admiration
ouais elle aurait pu y aller c'est
quelles vont être les nouveaux passages
voilà pour laëtitia n'a préparé quoi
elle va faire quoi bella c'est
l'offensive c'est versailles s'accorde à
le signer sceller series et en français
alors là c'est les risées en france l on
le sait les quatre enfants doivent
hériter
c'est ce que l'on souhaite depuis le
début cette nuit on souhaite jean louis
de son bonheur mais petite info voilà je
peux être que je vais rencontrer
laetitia ces prochains jours non voilà
oui pendant qu'elle a peut-être je vais
rencontrer ce serait bien je vous dirais
voilà comment ça se passe
voilà et et je vous dis parce que moi
j'ai jamais rencontrée laetitia voilà et
c'est vrai que j'étais un grand grand
fan de johnny et c'est vrai qu'on a tous
envie de savoir
voilà ce qui se passe autour de cette
histoire et moi quand je vois les fans
est-ce que vous l'aimez laetitia ah oui
oui les mets ben oui oui donc voilà je
ne suis pas fière c'est parce que les
fans fait partie de la gauche de fans
est ce que les fans voilà il inquiète on
aime bien qu'il aime pas en avant très
vite dans la plupart l'aiment pas sans
partager ses 25 ans oui qu'est ce qui se
passe dans michel non mais tu
heureusement qu'ils les maires ce que
s'ils ne l'aimé pas qu'est ce que ça
serait il pas son talent lui cracher
dessus toute la journée
bah on leur a volé quelque part l'homme
de leur vie parce que c'est vrai que les
fans sont témoins conditionnelle je
trouve ça abusé faut aller très
politicien alors s'il devrait y laisser
trop tard hier isaac les fans un mariage
vous avez fait un pèlerinage sur la
tombe de johnny exacte et vous souhaiter
que la tombe de lui reviennent bien sûr
à paris j'aimerais bien oui quelles
qu'elles soient plus ah bah ouais c'est
le voeu de tous les fans elle après pas
aussi parce qu'on respecte la volonté de
johnny bien sûr mais c'est vrai que
contrairement à ce qu'on peut dire -
pour y avoir passé dix jours
quand on entend qu'il ya des centaines
de fans qui sont là chaque jour
moi je suis resté dix jours en passant
trois fois par jour je peux vous dire si
en dix jours j'ai rencontré 15 ou 20
fans
j'en ai pas rencontrés plus c'est un
accord donc c'est du mytho talgo me
tourne à voir ce que vous en pensez
laetitia at elle le droit de retrouver
l'amour oui à 81%
non sans appel on est 2 en attaque aux
rations moi je pensais que ça allait
être un déferlement
c'est une et vous me dites donc ça la
soulager les souffrances car voilà et
bernard montiel nous le confirme bien
sûr bien sûr
quant à meaux et tant mieux moi je suis
très content qu'elle ait retrouvé
l'amour ça va adoucir et aplanir un peu
les relations avec les neiges va très
bien on va sur cette histoire elle est à
paris 1 laëtitia
sachez le elle est arrivée aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui voilà pour régler toute
cette affaire et c'est vrai que c'est
pas là il ya plein de gens voilà qui ont
refait leur vie et c'est vrai que sur
elles c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que
pour les autres